now joe biden's supreme court nominee
katanji brown jackson faced questions
from the senate today during the second
day of her confirmation hearings but
unlike democrats republicans they
focused on judge jackson's record her
judicial philosophy and expose the
democratic double standards when it
comes to republican nominees that dates
back decades here's senators graham and
cruz from earlier today take a look
do you know janice rogers brown
yes i do know her did you know that joe
biden actively filibustered janice
rogers brown
i did not know that there are two
standards going on here
if you're an african-american
conservative woman you're fair game to
have your life turned upside down to be
filibustered no matter how
qualified you are
and if you express your faith as a
conservative all of a sudden you're a
effing nut look at the freaking afghan
government it's made up of former
detainees at gitmo this whole
thing by the left about this war ain't
working
let me also note that larry thompson who
served as deputy attorney general under
so judge jackson all of us will agree
that that no one should be discriminated
against because of race
when you just testified a minute ago
that you didn't know if critical race
theory was taught in k through 12 i i
will confess i i find that statement a
little hard to reconcile
with the public record i do not believe
that any child
should be made to feel
as though they are
racist or though they are
not valued or though they are less than
that they're victims that they are
oppressors i don't
believe in any of that and i'll confess
judge jackson as as look as i listen to
your testimony i believe you are someone
who is compassionate i believe you care
for children obviously your children and
other children
but i also see a record
of activism and advocacy as it concerns
sexual predators
that stems back decades and that is
concerning
you say requirements that sex offenders
register
may or may not be unconstitutional
depending upon whether quote
sex
in which sex offenders have no privacy
right and registration information or
blood samples so you suggest that may or
may not be constitutional you raise
doubts about it do you still agree with
the sentiments you expressed in your law
school note
respectfully senator those are not the
sentiments that i expressed in my law
school note
now the hearings will continue tomorrow
and are scheduled to conclude on
thursday here now with morris texas
senator
ted cruz is with us senator
i want to start with this she wrote once
that every judge
has
a personal hidden agenda
and when i heard that i'm thinking
um what is what is her what is her
hidden agenda we ever get an answer on
that
well no and and when it came to critical
race theory she didn't want to answer
the question she claimed she didn't
really know what it was or what it
contained of course she had previously
given a speech at a law school where she
said that sentencing what judges do
uh involves critical race theory and and
i got to say there was a lot of
discussion about her record
when it concerns sexual offenders and in
particular sexual predators targeted at
kids as as you just played i asked her
about what she wrote in law school that
that that suggested that the laws that
many states have passed providing for
civil commitment for violent sexual
predators that those laws are
unconstitutional and and you know we
went through every single case that
she's presided over as a district judge
where the defendant was convicted of
possession of child pornography every
case that she had discretion in
she consistently sentenced the defendant
to substantially below the sentencing
guidelines and substantially below what
the prosecutor asked for over and over
and over again she averaged sentencing
them
48 percent less than the prosecutor
asked for and that was in a hundred
percent of the cases where she had
discretion where there wasn't a plea
agreement or a mandatory minimum
sentence it it really is a disturbing
pattern and when she was asked for
example one case
involved an 18 year old man who had
multiple videos explicit videos of young
children
12 year olds 11 10 as young as 8 years
old engaged in in explicit sexual
activity in one instance being the
victim of a violent rape and she
sentenced the the 18 year old man who
had these videos on his computer to just
three months in jail the federal
sentencing guideline said 10 years she
gave him three months and and i gotta
say when she was asked about it she
couldn't give a good explanation about
why repeatedly she gave light sentences
lenient sentences to sex offenders when
the law didn't didn't uh support that
i i watched the exchange i couldn't
believe it myself senator i want to go
back to critical race theory more
specifically i believe the speech you
were referring to was at michigan's law
school
and she had praised the 1619 project
which argues fundamentally that the u.s
is a racist country
and
in that speech correct me if i'm wrong
did she not make clear that judges that
she believes should consider crt in
sentencing
that's explicitly what she said is that
sentencing she was talking about how
interesting sentencing is and she says
it involves lots of things
including critical race theory and and
when i asked her about it she initially
contended she had no idea what it was
and and that it had nothing to do with
her job and then i confronted her with
her own quote
saying that sentencing involves critical
race theory and she didn't have an
answer to that and it look it's a little
bit of the game unfortunately that we've
seen from biden judicial nominees where
they claim to have no philosophy they
claim not to know anything about
whatever they believe and and and then
they get on the bench and they vote hard
hard left and i think there's real
reasons uh to have concerns that if
judge jackson becomes justice jackson
that that we will see a vote on the far
left very possibly the furthest left of
any of the nine justices particularly on
criminal justice issues it's an odd
thing but but for 30 years
she has been advocating lighter
sentences more lenient treatment for
sexual offenders both sexual offenders
who target kids and just in general sex
offenders and i gotta say that that
doesn't make any sense to me and i think
to most americans what about the issue
of court packing she refuses to answer
that question uh i'm a little surprised
why she refuses to answer that question
simple question she says it's a policy
issue do you see a constitutional
question involved
well it there's not a constitutional
barrier to packing the court congress
has the authority to alter the number of
justices and over the years congress has
but for over a hundred years it's been
set at nine
the person who she's been nominated to
replace steve breyer has said we should
stay at nine ruth bader ginsburg who
passed away
just over a year ago she said it should
stay at nine and so judge jackson just
doesn't want to answer it and i think
part of the reason she doesn't want to
answer it is the people who are actively
supporting her nomination the people who
lobbied the biden white house for a
nomination the people who have devoted
and pledged over a million dollars to a
campaign in support of her nomination
they're the radical extreme left they've
described the constitution as quote
trash and they're the ones pushing the
campaign to pack the supreme court and
so justice uh judge jackson did did not
want to address a view one way or the
other on the question
um i i notice there is a great
difference between say the way democrats
treat republican
uh nominees to the court i'll name a few
names robert bohr clarence thomas
justice cavanaugh more recently
do you see any of your republican
colleagues uh like lisa murkowski i
assume mitt romney and and the usuals uh
supporting her nomination
look i think it's certainly possible i
think the names you suggest uh would not
shock me to see them vote uh in in favor
of this confirmation i i hope that they
don't do that but but on any close
contested political issue you can see
them
casting a vote with the democrats um
what i hope every republican doesn't for
that matter what democrats ought to do
is look to her record and ask is this a
justice that would defend the
constitution as you know the book i
wrote two years ago one vote away how a
single supreme court seat can change
history that outlines how free speech
religious liberty the second amendment
they all hang in the balance and we
ought to ask would this justice protect
our constitutional rights well do they
believe in co-equal branches of
government or do they believe they can
legislate from the bench do they believe
in the constitution or not pretty simple
questions important principles and you
all we get are prepared talking points
and many hearings that's what i felt
like we were getting today senator thank
you good to see you